avete presente ragazzi la copla coffin
dance c'è un livello chiamato coffin
dance
vediamo come bisogno di apertura ragazzi
di dire di fare coffin dance because yes
prima vedere cosa esce fuori ragazzi
credo che effettivamente si sono
concentrati sulla confidenza sia un
livello della madonna
se mi concentro posso sentire la musica
ragazzi solo se mi concentro
ma dove stia finendo regalo ma che mi
hanno seppellito vittoria va bene ok non
mi ricordavo finisse così in meno
abbiamo scoperto dove va a finire la
bara da confin del niger sguazzato avevo
già addocchiato ligia warrior allo
ragazzi ninja warrior era un party che
mio cugino ha partecipato a ninja
warrior incredibili ragazzi questo è il
mio cugino vi giuro
stefano grande esterna farvi vedere ecco
allora in questa è una cosa che vivi vi
racconto io fantastica faremo un
episodio tutta roba di rock etnico
deciso che raccontano rime cugini non li
stefano questo è il mio ninja mario
stefano goditelo allora ecco a posto
abbiamo finito ecco la differenza tra me
e lui non sono solo i muscoli e anche la
capacità di superare gli ostacoli allora
proviamoci un attimo perché se non
riesco a fare figure di merda e possiamo
andare io a fare le scalate no non le
facciamo perché quanto pare non è male
banco su happy with e mi alleno zeppe
sono 65 anni che faccio ok a dio
stefano spiega micrometriche non è
possibile al remagen com'è possibile
spiegatevi se è veramente difficilissimo
è molto più facile di quanto pensassi mm
in tv sembra facile ma vacca care allora
ok
ecco non è tanto le gambe non servono
stai tranquillo per arrampicarti vai
senza chi è
devo prendere quel corso ma è
difficilissimo lo devo dovevo afferrare
con le marche lo dovrebbe entrarci colpo
perché veramente difficile ragazzo o
proviamo un attimo serio perfetto meno
male che mi sono staccato con la schiena
perché non ce l'avrei mai fatta se no
speriamo non ci sia da fare null'altro
col poco perché sono finito non ce l'ho
a dovevo usare il tuorlo quanto pare
mannaggia buttati giù lo stesso
sbattitene vai giù bravo attenzione è
quello dove
il poco non ce l'ho più non ce l'ho
vado senza prendiamo senza ok sono vivo
tutto bene non ho le braccia ma tutto a
prof
credo che vinciamo orio si sa molto di
più delle mie possibilità
foto walk come camminare cottura di
iniziare dalle masi dovrebbe perché
questo c'è il collo di maurizio costanzo
auto walk with us work up your ass 3
scontro le shift alternativo di cose è
vero ma come non lo sapevo
si può camminare in sé è primi a saperlo
prima sai quante e quante vittorie
facevo ma sai quante volte mi è capitato
di avere una spada nel culo suo ep tutti
i john frog swing venga effettivamente
perchè gli ho quindi non ne facciamo da
un secolo dc ha già scritto rock swing
delle capacità non al corrimano porco il
demonio quindi scendiamo babygap bene ma
essere un rock swing e tanta roba i
ragazzi sono tutti uguali
abito qui bello ragazzi per una volta un
livello fatto da cristo è fatto
veramente bene sembra mi sono staccato
una gamba ma fa niente né rock swing non
servono belghe fatte viburno sempre le
gambe il tuo gioco però ok molto bene
molto belle ma adora come mi sono
salvato tantissimo sotto il motivo ok ok
devo ficcarmi cidenti troppo amazing
dove sono al contrario
non ho capito niente di quello che è
successo per ora per il pocho è però
lascia nelle palle spero di non perdere
a questo perché ci sta mettendo una vita
solo per partire ok che bello il
contesto pro porca vacca ogni volta deve
aspettare sei ore allocco in perfetto
halloween
ok adesso vai su win che giocatore anni
anni di epica ma di che parliamo ways to
die il caricamento del caricamento cioè
peggio di così ciao e quindi ho capito
in che senso a questi sono quelli che tu
schiacci e vedi come vuole la gente
tabla più
sono curioso fa vedere tutto a posto
quando dicono don trevisiol non so se
guardavate la cosa che ripetevano sempre
don't try this at home
don't rise e non c'è non provarlo a casa
ecco perché in tutto questo mi stanno
speculando il secondo scenario grazie
dei manager it
ok black friday che questo sessuali di
como in america almeno 90 per cento ma è
giusto
epic giochi e mi sa che non è mai
riuscito cd live you your words nappi
non ho capito shot gun ok
purtroppo non andare sul die percorso
studiato bene questo è il miglior
livello del genere che abbiamo mai viste
bagni ex no ai ds questo per gli
youtubers
basta e stato bello cioè dovrebbe farlo
ogni tanto tempo sahin prego opinion joy
un sacco zio potrò tanto per cambiare
però farlo serio stavolta win questo che
era più semplice è uscito a perdono
let's go on the winning ho detto che
dovevo morire per farlo kill the town è
già in tour col martello a me overwatch
borsa trottola che botta terminati o
minchia che schiaffo forti chi dica
ecco probabilmente anche questione più
misura le armi e spaccati occupata una
gran festa è stato fortissimo bellissimo
90 nei processi fosse stato poi es
o no ce la faccio tranquillo ce la
faccio no ora gala è veramente
impossibile questo non so come diavolo
potrei mai fare ah ok ci ho fatto
scherzavo effettivamente non ho capito
la dinamica di alcuni ostacoli negli
anni questo a quanto pare non è così
semplice
madonna il poco però ha vinto c'è porca
vacca è il livello più difficile che
abbia mai provato c'è una benedizione ed
è 1 e del fumo le nei primi c'è parco
demonio come te ecco perché non avevo
mai pasta che non si può provenire credo
madonna bastavano voi più fare facciamo
il primissimo mio ragazzi c'è search by
level name fa vigenti il primo livello
fatto per me
e fa vige ti sfido di samo 64 gamer
ok va bene amico mio problema vedere per
parigi
attento ma che sa che questo amore mai
non andare indietro
ti conosco benissimo lo sapevi che sarei
andato bravo signor lavoro già fatto
studi velo ma non me lo ricordo
assolutamente assolutamente vedere che
cosa è successo
però mi sono salvato
mi sono salvato che incredibile non
andare avanti a questo punto ha detto ok
lo so che non è facile suo livello vento
una sega quanto fa due più due quattro o
un pesce come due fantagenitori un pesce
guala arabona quale suo palazzo
i mostri a mente sono colpe né o senza
pene senza pene senso ma il senso della
vita
23 del mese perché ricordi a mese
ragazzi che ricordi incredibili conosci
ti do magic official ciao vi do un bacio
te voglio bene che ci ricordano tutti
bocciati
le the gosh ainslie sono incastrato
quindi curva
davanti l'acqua perché non posso andare
avanti da 18 perfetto qui facilissimo
qual è la tua frase più famosa dove sono
i corn flakes o dove la bella la mia
frase più famosa e bella a tutti i
ragazzi
usciamo di qui
aspetta
continua vai avanti c'è una sorpresa
continua così belli se un grande ciao
bello se non sei famiglie iscritti al
suo canale facciamo diventare famosa in
tutta youtube
beh grazie quindi io devo il mio
successo a samu 60 grazie siamo mai vedi
ragazzi questo è a livello di oggi sono
contento della cof intenso e vi
raccontano di mio cugino in un prossimo
vita a quanto pare perché secondo me è
una cosa africa parola reaction a queste
cose velenje jolo forse il viso un
ragazzo in bacino mischiati al canale
dai ragazzi
[Musica]
ma